staying alive in the post-apocalyptic
Moscow Metro is no easy task
for starters there's a long list of
things trying to kill you let's see what
do we have here radiation bandits Nazis
oh great that ideology survived
communists wait a minute then to what
happen to my enemy's enemy is my friend
and then of course there's all the
hideous mutants there's the wolf like
Watchmen horrendous giant spider bunk
things very angry shrimp flying demons
and librarians it's not what you think I
didn't touch your books leave me alone
this extensive list of dangers means
that survival know-how and combat
technique is essential in the world of
Metro so let's take a look back at these
key skills in Metro 2033 and last lights
and see how they've evolved in the
upcoming third game in the series Metro
XS
survival in the Metro is all about skill
subtlety and grabbing every single gas
mask filter you can get your hands on
claustrophobic combat with ferocious
mutants while your watch slowly ticks
away the remaining seconds of available
oxygen is the heart and soul of the
Metro series these filters along with
all other useful resources are in super
short supply so a keen scavenger sense
is essential also don't be afraid to
stray from the path to hunt for extra
supplies aha see a shotgun
sorry about that that should have been
do be afraid like all the time but it's
not just guns and supplies you need to
keep your eyes open for ammunition is
perhaps the most valuable thing to
scavenge in the metro literally in the
case of 2033 and last light as
military-grade ammunition is the
currency in the underground tunnels this
works out rather nicely as there's no
need to carry wads of cash plus if your
gun runs empty you can always reload and
save your life with your life savings I
am the angel of death
I mean Dead's I'm now completely broken
and Metro Exodus however a bullet based
economy is no longer the case on the
surface which means you can put all that
ammunition into dealing with the myriad
of dangers being on the surface also
means there are many more useful bits
and pieces to Hoover up as you explore
the partially irradiated Russian
wilderness all of which feeds into a
brand new crafting system in 2033 and
last light weapons could be customized
by adding makeshift stocks suppressors
and sights however an exodus this system
has been expanding massively allowing
you to create a unique handcrafted
arsenal simply head to your nearest
outpost and hit up the crafting table to
retool your favorite gun it's not just
about weapons though armor and gear can
also be upgraded and repaired from items
scavenged in the sandbox field but what
if you're not in the safety of the
outpost and desperately need a new
filter for your gas masks before you
horribly suffocate well fear not because
now you can craft on the fly from your
handy backpack when it comes to combat
in Exodus as with all the metro series
taking a stealthy and subtle approach is
usually the best plan Plus thanks to the
new sandbox environments you now have
far more choice when engaging the enemy
you can approach from any direction you
like and any time of day at any weather
want to attack those cultists in the
dead of night during a torrential
downpour for example fill your rain
sodden boots that said you don't always
have to kill the human fools in your way
stealthy avoidance and non-lethal
takedowns are definite options if you do
get spotted however enemies will
actively seek you out and those of the
human variety will communicate an
attempt to flush you into the open
so once the murderous cat is out of the
bag you can go lowered with guns grenade
are even by shooting laps causing them
to explode and spew helpful fire
thanks fire should you ultimately gain
the upper hand some enemies may even
spontaneously surrender at the mere
sight of you
now I'm the angel of decency and once
all the dust settles from the fire fight
make sure not to forget to clean your
guns weapon maintenance is new to Exodus
and if you take care of your arsenal
they will take care of you da so
adorable next week in the third and
final installment we'll delve into the
main characters and factions awaiting
you in the wilds of post-apocalyptic
Russia
[Music]
played on the world's most powerful
console
[Music]